hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
unboxing video and in this one we'll be
unboxing the HP Pavilion dv6 T 16 inch
laptop from Best Buy so let's just get
right into this guys first of all I want
to apologize to you guys because the
audio quality in this video is not going
to be as good thing usually is with the
gn3 microphone however I will do my best
to demonstrate you know and show you
guys everything that comes with the DV
16 and also this laptop is available at
the link in the description also you can
get this at Best Buy comm or in probably
your local Best Buy store so let's just
go ahead and open this right up and I'll
talk to you guys a little bit about it
because it is the it's kind of a
pre-configured model this isn't
customizable this is a preset model of 4
gigs of ram all that stuff and you can't
you can't changing it and just get this
one base model so I'm I'll just go ahead
and not open this right up then that's
exactly go ahead and see what comes in
the box now I unfortunately wasn't able
to unbox my DV 17 sorry the contents of
this package are very similar plastic
strip on top I'll kind of show you guys
what's in the box here there is the line
the cardboard there it is guys I'll get
to that in a minute we move this aside
I'm actually going to show you what
comes else in the box so just go ahead
and take this out there's also a little
our HP strip that actually shows you a
little bit of information about you know
being two laptops getting it set up the
battery all that good stuff you'll
probably find something like this in any
laptop in boxing moving on the actual
contents of the package now like I said
this is not customizable however the
battery that comes with this so I'm
going to have to seal this bubble wrap
but it is a 12
battery so if I cut and show you it's a
pretty large battery and it's going to
stick out the back of the laptop a good
a fair amount with the 16 inch laptop so
I'm just letting you guys know the 12th
low battery is what comes with the
configuration in the description along
here is your power cable and your power
brick a very very small power brick if
you guys I don't know if you know how
big my hands are but you've seen the
size of my pocketknife now just go ahead
and show you real quick it is pretty
pretty small power brick guys so
definitely I may be able to go portable
and no matter if you have a huge battery
and a very small power brick you're
gonna be able to go mobile anytime you
want now there's also this little mini
booklet basically HP telling you you can
take notes and use all this awesome
software it comes with it the restore
your system without a disk I don't know
if you guys can see it but that booklet
is also included with every HP model HP
laptop your microfiber you might have
seen one of these in all my videos
this comes with HP laptops as well and
actually the the remote that comes with
the actually with every HP laptop there
is this remote that I just flies right
into the PCI Express cards but you don't
get this with other saying it dell'Orto
shivah laptops you only get this
included automatically within HP so
again I'm just going to move this out of
the way so you guys can see everything
the last and most important part of this
laptop is that it comes with windows 7
upgrade for free and that is pretty much
one of the primary reasons my dad
actually got this black pops so um yeah
this isn't actually mine I'm not
unboxing another laptop for you guys
bring out your laptop itself now I want
to go too into this I'm gonna let the
actual owner of this laptop take care of
it but as you can see there's these
little corrugated cardboard pieces on
the sides
no biggie and the laptop and stuff if
the laptop if the 16 inch laptop has the
two headphone jacks on the front I'll go
ahead and I
you guys can speak let me just get a
size comparison with some other common
household objects so item six or seven
now what HP does the pretty much one of
the big parts of the notebook is that
it's a big fingerprint magnet so they
have this sort of a plastic on the
outside not a big deal but um you can
take this off whenever you want cool
little design and to open the laptop up
you'll go out there go back to sort of
screen protector thing that a lot help
it not be too intrusive with the
keyboard so that's not a big deal here's
a laptop itself all black interior with
the color matching keyboard as I said
before it's a 16 inch laptop all the
specs and off everything you might need
to know about it will be in the
description and you guys can check that
out too now if you guys have any burning
questions about the laptops feel free to
ask and I'll try to do my best and let
you guys know what comes with it and any
software or hardware questions you guys
have and one of the things not a lot of
people knew was that the four gigs of
ram that come pre-installed with this
are definitely going to work with
Windows Vista Home Premium 64-bit and
that is in fact two two gigs of RAM
sticks so that is basically it for this
unboxing you guys just letting you guys
know what comes in the boxes you're
planning on buying so it says laptop
again the huge social battery is gonna
last you a good seven seven and a half
hours so if you guys are planning on
going mobile with a laptop of this size
you're definitely going to want to
invest in something with a large battery
so with a free windows 7 upgrade like I
mentioned before and that is a split so
thank you guys for watching this
unboxing video of the HP Pavilion dv6 P
stay tuned for more unboxing videos just
go ahead and open this up just cuz it
looks cool
stay tuned for more unboxing videos and
there's me any reflection there you can
see me walk the screen obviously but uh
thank you for watching this unboxing
guys and I'll talk to you guys in the
next video peace